خشيه من تكرار سيناريو خرسان ومن قبله
خاركيز يواصلوا الجيش الروسي والقوات
الانفصاليه المواليه له التركيز على جبهات
مقاطعه في دنيا شرقيه اوكرانيا في ظل
المكاسب الميدانيه التي نجحها في تحقيقها
الايام الماضيه ف فضلا عن تمكنهما من
انتزاع المناطق كانت تحت سيطره الجيش
الاوكراني لا سيما في محيط المحوري
كوبيانز شمال غربيه
فانهما نجح ايضا في صد محاولات الجيش
الاوكراني باستعاده المواقعك كان قد خسرها
جنوبي المقاطعه في المقابل يؤكد الجيش
الاوكراني انه صدم محاولات تقدم للجيش
الروسي في دون بس رغم ان تلك المحاولات
رافقها قصف مدفعي وصاروخي طال كرامات هولك
وعددا من المناطق التي لا تزال تحت سيطرتك
في دنياك في مقاطعه الزابولوجيا جنوب شرقي
البلاد
اتهمت السلطات الاخرانيه الجيش الرو
بمواصله سياسه قصف البنا التحتيه الحيويه
داخل ما تسميه الجزء المحرره من زبرجيا في
حين يؤكد الجيش الاوكراني انه نجح في
تدمير مستودعات ذخيره وايقاع عدد من
الاصابات في صفوف القوات الروسيه بعد قصف
شانه على مدينه مليت بول التي تعتبرها
موسكو العاصمه المؤقته لزابولوجيا سيناريو
القصف الروسي المكثف تركز ايضا على الجزء
الخاضع للسيطره الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه
خرسان اذ تقول سلطاتك ان عددا من المدنيين
سقطوا بين قتيل وجريح بسبب القصف المتواصل
على مركز المقاطعه وبانها بدات باجلاء
المرضى من المستشفيات خرسون الى مناطق
اكثر امنا بل انها نصحه المدنيين بمغادره
المدينه بسبب الضرر البالغ الذي تعرضت له
البنيه التحتيه هناك وعجز السلطات عن
توفير الخدمات الاساسيه لهم مسلسل القص
روسيه قال كذلك مناطق خارج الاقاليم
الاربعه التي ضمتها موسكو اليها اتقولوا
شرطه دنيبرو ثالث كبرى مدن اوكرانيا ان
عددا من الجرحى سقطوا نتيجه قصف صاروخيه
استهدف احد احياء المدينه وان الرجال
الانقاذ يعملون على رفع الانقاض والبحث عن
عدد من المفقودين في الحي السكني المستهدف
[موسيقى]